foreign
[Music]
Hello everybody welcome good morning
welcome to Bullet brawl
okay so I'm gonna play Hikaru in game
one as usual
of course
it's done
your location
all right um
probably wouldn't by taking B7
um
why would I do that
oh my gosh
all right
what a game
ikaro was always this fast all right
here we go first game is a drop
I could have won there but I I was too
conservative
I was very impressive about your car
that was that was very fast
that was that was like your car's speed
from 15 years ago
but I'm honored that he saves it for
people like me like he doesn't do it
against anybody
okay it's a bad move
three
let's go here and here
hmm
okay just making some random moves here
and white is better but not much better
I'm gonna win on time
hopefully
yeah
it's good
okay
okay six I mean
wow the car will like defense except I
don't think he's gonna have a car like
speed
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
the best way to lose this game
okay thank you
care
oh
check
ah
slippery
what am I doing
I'm gonna wait on time but
too too long
too freaking long
you can't win games in five minutes in
bullet brawl
it doesn't help that the people never
resign here but
okay triumphante I lost to him in the
last Boulevard let's play an alkyne
okay nice silicon
this is already resignable for white by
the way
okay not the way I played it okay now I
can maybe take care
[Music]
I was wondering that too Akil in fact I
was considering not starting the bullet
bra until people told me what picaro had
said minute by minute
I've been doing very well in the bullet
brawls I've I've been doing better in
the leeches titled Arenas partially you
can see car is not playing
I mean not partially that is literally
the only reason I do well in a title
Arenas because the car is not playing
okay well black is completely winning
but unfortunately people won't resign
here
I'm up three pawns coming the Knight to
D3 getting the Knight to D3
okay come on
another Pawn
this one I think will be the last straw
he doesn't have any more left to blunder
Wrecking Ball 67.
all right wrecking ball let's see what
you got
um now I take here
what
this work if I take here it's gonna go
Bishop D4
I feel like he's gonna go Knight C4
Queen B3 oh I gotta be careful let's
just give that pawn up
ugh this is exactly how you lose games
to people like this
you get into these sharp positions and
then anything can happen
well such as him blundering a rock
and made on the next move
okay David is the one I gotta be I gotta
be David
okay let's just play the way nehal plays
it
I have six interesting what
is the idea of this
[Music]
yeah I saw that
I guess I can go here maybe
wait why didn't I go Queen D2 I'm such
an idiot it doesn't matter fence poses
[Music]
foreign
I made the one one way I found the one
way to keep the game going
okay straight queens and wind Daniel
awful attack oh my gosh look it doesn't
matter
he just has no time unfortunately
I just have to be careful in case he
puts his Rook on free
why did I do that
board Nick
and that was a nice game I played well I
mean I I never let the win go
this main line
okay I don't know E6 that well
[Music]
reposition the ropes
all right let's go back to G1
um
okay I'm gonna go for mate here I could
have taken the bond when we go for mate
whoa Anonymous the subs I see those
thank you
yeah the problem is you're here
my queen of strapped I don't know
okay I should probably go Rook up one
here
and win the game
I think I went on the spot
or do I Rook C1 B3 simply
okay the real Emoji this guy's good
let's play an alkyne
um
I was gonna premium Queen C7 I think I
didn't
okay
oh my God
what did I do
to go like this
yeah but he can't take
um
this is all right
this is okay for me
right he can take actually uh
probably take that but okay
letter D5
wow
I I had a feeling this guy would beat me
wait here maybe last
here oh I'm close to actually surviving
this
I might survive this
yes I'm gonna survive this I'm gonna win
I'm gonna win
he had rookie five but he's losing in
the end game
[Music]
it's waiting to pair me against the car
this is this is the ridiculous thing it
like Waits and waits and waits and waits
at some point and doesn't give you a
natural pairing but it's fine
[Music]
do do
do do do do
do do do do do do
all right
all right let's go here
gosh shoot
forgot about that pawn and who cares
it's an Apon
so it's a matter of bullet
did I trap his Queen probably not
gonna trap his Queen Maybe
go like this
oh
my buttered C3
what am I doing
no I've learned
[__]
that was bad I was completely winning
out of the opening completely winning
I found the only way
always happens to Jasmine
[Music]
we gotta build a different a new streak
immediately
can't convert against anybody here in
the early going
idiots
same thing happening here
[Music]
foreign
he's messing this up a little bit
[Music]
they don't blunder your plane
I'm just D3 that win the game it does
win the game
it was important to stop Amman because
he was actually in front
okay Iman you don't have time 20 seconds
to one my man okay Terry is in front
right now I'm in second hikar was in
third
yeah that's that sucked that last
adjustment was really really hurt my
chances
that's where I could have broken out
gotta be better all right Pedro Martinez
this guy's pretty decent
Everybody Plays B3 here and it's wrong
and block is already much better
this one's for black
go back
I feel like unleash as people resign in
these types of positions
but on chess.com they fight
okay you had a better move there
I'm really concerned because I'm playing
very well but my conversion has been
awful again I'm screwing this up
oh and I miss tricky1 and Knight C7
doing
okay at least I got centralized
oh he took that's bad
yeah now I'm should be winning again
grab this guy so he doesn't get a pass
Pawn
grab this guy
go back
okay how do I win this maybe check
check
that was also really stupid but
it's gonna pay dividends
the minor p7 game and win
stalemate we're good
[Music]
the black is bad right here but it's
hard to play
I don't know why I put the Knight on
before
[Music]
F5 is my idea
shoot
I managed to blunder wait but I have
this
um
and now everyone
H4 Unstoppable
I almost managed to screw up with
winning position out of the opening but
not quite I tried very hard but not hard
enough
your car is on Kick and follow him on
kick
thank you
okay let's hope your resigns
a lot of bullet brawl is all about like
when people resign and and those
incremental seconds
okay this is made in one
okay come on come on dude
all right it's time there we go
okay quick one let's get let's see if we
can get an easy game here just to Butch
rest of my lead
oh
top pairing wait why am I
okay let's play some mono which I don't
even freaking play
and I used to play it but not anymore
I don't like E6 oh shoot
of course
preparation oh and I blow another thing
okay nice
okay but it's not it's not I'm not dead
here
oh this is why I need to play my real
openings
against people in bullet because they
throw out all their preparation at me
forgot about this dumb trick
and he's gonna get nervous
I hope he's gonna make a mistake
he already did
okay now I'm in the game again
go what is C1 he wants H4
you just centralized
um
yeah 905 winning on the spot
here
okay I guess just takes in like here
yeah the problem is you now pushes to
spawn
I don't see it
okay is there mate
Jack
there is me
I win
beautiful
one down a queen
okay it's waiting to pair me with
another hikar this is what it freaking
does when the car was in first
Place yeah when I'm at first I play
Chicago
foreign
ah
okay if I don't win this there's no hope
for me in chess or in life
okay now I'm up a full piece not he
doesn't even have a pawn for the piece
I'm literally up a freaking piece why am
I already screwing this up
okay let's go C4
that's another stupid move but whatever
unbelievable what am I doing okay at
least I got
okay that's another Dumbo
to condense ozen
um
am I giving everything up right now
but I'm still winning
like completely winning
like oh my God there we go another one
no I was so winning that like I
literally like literally I'm like yeah
like I literally yeah it's a win
so trigger right now
oh my gosh
so annoying
um let's guess a king's side
oh should I have 135 oh my God
just kidding there is Bishop B7
oh [__]
okay wait this guy's this guy's good I
need to be careful
oh shoot
oh my God he's got Rook D1 but then I
got Rook E1
okay let's just go back to up one
I need to play more actively I can't do
this against these players
okay before defend the pawn
gotta play more actively
Zach bonds let's go play for the clock
oh
okay just keep the piece what am I doing
for takes A2 but every one of those
moves is costing him like five seconds
he's not he's obviously not gonna make
it unless I want her mating one or
something
which is not impossible
okay whatever
it doesn't matter because he has no time
okay we're playing Hikaru again I mean
that's just yeah
summer when the car was in first it
wasn't giving me a car like at all
[Music]
91.
let's crush him maybe a four no I don't
like
um
I think now F4 makes sense
ig3 F3
okay
can I get away with this move probably
[Music]
takes King
ah but I wanted to change
whatever
no I okay whatever
oh mate
easy clap easy clap not even close
in the time scramble
[Music]
okay this wins for white
it's all in the chorus in this
particular line
this just ends it but will he resign
down up no you see that's the thing
down a full rook and down 20 seconds
no
let's keep oh but I mean probably you
shouldn't resign against me
oh he won a pawn back congrats very nice
it's it's
okay again we're playing Ohio
foreign
trying to play very positionally against
him
all right Cena mobile head ugh
up bearing
okay board Nick's also like on a huge
roll so gotta continue winning
[Music]
yeah but he goes A5
um let's go for some sex Maybe
let's go for a for a night sack it feels
right to do this because that Rook C5
Bishop B5 also
oh I had that immediately and I would
have won
wait what am I doing
why am I still going for it let's go
here
okay I wanted to eliminate this Pawn I
thought that was very important
okay wait Knight of course let's take
let's just play a very simple chess
I don't know Bishop 3 feels right to get
another passer
yeah but I'm I'm losing the thread
completely
until he blunder is made in one of
course but who couldn't anticipate that
okay we're playing fairchini let's play
an alkyne
I should have taken to the queen
probably
[Music]
um
let's go up to D5
and then A4
what country is this this is Bolivia
okay I'm completely winning here
until I blunder a piece see this is
exactly
okay let's not panic let's find the best
objective continuation and flag them on
time
no problem
he has no time he's not gonna make it
yeah there's no way he makes it this is
going to take a little bit longer than I
was hoping but I'm still gonna win
no need for Primos just play calmly
okay not the best game but we got the
job done
okay on shoot again that's in that's an
easier one it's one alakhine
probably not the greatest position to go
into against 2100.
but that's fine
yeah he would do that
let's take
just play play on the clock here a
little bit
why did I do that though that was really
stupid
okay that was my whole idea I literally
had one trick in the book and I I
carried it out
okay resign resign resign come on come
on come on dude come on dude
come on man
it's not nice
I mean it's just low oh Magnus is
playing oh damn Magnus is playing and
he's late
okay I gotta keep winning Magnus is
playing shoot
the papa papa is here Papa
where's his side Papa came to show
everybody who the Tsar is
I mean I've been if you haven't noticed
I've been playing a bullet tournament so
I haven't noticed I haven't I don't even
care about the standings I'm just
playing the best that I can and that's
it
but I got this basically means I have to
win every single game for the rest of
the bullet brawl
I have to win them really really fast
too
no terrible move
wait what am I doing I forgot about
Bishop takes F3
I'm still completely winning but now
it's gonna take a little bit longer
which is okay
okay wait let's think here let's not
let's not give him oh shoot E4
what am I doing
[Music]
I'm not allowed to lose this game come
on dude
what did I just freaking do
here
Brooke and mathe from Turkey
okay here
okay let's run on my own two feet
yeah okay this is good this is very very
good this means he's not gonna make it
I was that was my one Achilles seal
today has been conversion of advantages
again again I'm playing badly here
okay obviously I'm gonna flag him
barely got that one
okay we're playing this guy beat me a
couple times Let's Play Another Kind
this guy's beating me on many occasions
actually so it's not let's not
relax against somebody so let's go D6
simple chest I could take on C5 there
but
yeah this is what I don't like about him
he's very very tactical oh and I blended
this
but I've wanted that but do I not have
um G3 G6 five Jesus
okay now I actually have to calculate
oh God I made it there oh my gosh
I guess I have to go like this
[Music]
and I think I should be in oh
yeah but this is garbage
this is garbage play
now I just go here
I blended Queen F3 which absolutely
should not have been allowed but I mean
it was stupid but it doesn't matter
I think I should be able to win this
I'm careful
okay this is the last hurdle I have to
find a move here
okay oh my gosh did I just want her
again
I did didn't I
okay now I just gotta play on time then
ah
oh no Daniel come on
oh my gosh dude
girl girl
oh my gosh this freaking guy
come on girl
that's unacceptable
if that happened against any good bullet
player that's an easy win for white
[Music]
a couple of games that I want to get
back let's play an alkyne
[Music]
foreign
don't mind that move as much
nope that was wrong
the problem is he can yeah of course he
finds that
this is problematic but it's not clear
who's winning here
okay he finds another insane move
let's see what am I doing here
okay I'm winning a piece
and the game
couple games there that I that I really
didn't play well Bortnick okay we're
playing Terry gotta win
board Nick has won 8 000 games in a row
as well of course where would we be
without Sasha going on a massive streak
now in the bishop B5 I blended
he had a winning tactic there
Terry doesn't really okay
let's just go here
it'll be four
no that was sloppy
there's no need to rush I don't know why
I freaking rushed like that
now I played another terrible move
always it's always Terry who stops me
always
dude is so hard to play against
unbelievable
you had Bishop B3 winning on the spot
oh geez come on
that was that was pathetic absolutely
pathetic
I'm still I'm gonna try something dirty
here
I was completely winning
just do anything except what I did
when I had it coming there's a couple
really bad games like that
stalemate
yeah
dudes
I mean I won something like 10 or 15
games in a row before that so
always Terry
just something about a style that makes
me makes me blunder
okay I gotta rebuild the streak really
quickly because Bortnick is catching up
okay ckg chess this guy's good but not
but very beatable
um wait here
game
gotta play more aggressively but take
more time in the middle game
[Music]
hmm
again I'm messing up
hahaha
the only move that allows it the only
move that allows it
Anastasia's meat
you don't get that often in actual chess
Anastasia's mate
all right this wins I know this wins but
I don't know exactly how so I'm just
gonna play quickly
I hope that I'm yeah of course I missed
that move but
it doesn't really matter oh and I missed
that move too but I have this and I
missed that move as well
ugh
why am I I'm really trying to mess this
up
okay I think I failed
yeah these 2600s are actually not bad
but they're they can find moves
these are not walk over wins despite
what it looks like okay now he's got to
resign
I'm gonna play down a full piece I see
and it's about 16 Pawns
really
there we go
okay that was an easier one German
bazaev okay this guy's good but not
great
yeah we had this before actually
if Knight takes D5 is a threat here yeah
he finds the right move
okay the end game is good for white I
think
I would also play yes dude if you don't
know my hypocrite by now then you
haven't been watching the Stream
I absolutely would not have resigned
there
so why are you yelling at people for not
rejoining
let's freaking go I had an Anastasia's
mate and a bowden's maid in one
tournament
can't believe it
um could play Knight 64 but let's just
keep the pieces on the board
wait takes 666 yeah
you're winning
okay this is just to grind it out affair
I'd a two over okay four winning Knight
T5 she takes takes takes
um
is this just end the game I think it
does
yeah it does in the game okay we're
playing Pedro Martinez
oh this freaking line I don't know how
to play at all I'm just gonna play
calmly
he almost beat me earlier
95 on
crap I was gonna and see pre-move him
so why did I do that that was really
stupid
that's okay lesson don't don't do that
stuff
resist the temptation you idiots okay
um let's go here
and blender another Pawn
okay so he wants that let's go F4
no I'm still fine here but I'm still
totally fine but
just it's a good lesson to not don't try
to cut Corners to win quickly against
good bullet players
everything's a lesson
and that's another terrible move now I'm
actually at risk of losing this game
it takes C4 he has
stuff
I'm gonna win but not the way I wanted
to okay salima she's a good player
let's win another one here
okay this is already almost winning for
white
Savannah's not stressful if you don't
make it stressful
it can just be fun also
[Music]
foreign
like garbage here
let's find this
trying to load up the complications here
God she's good
[Music]
okay I think if I take there
yeah blender rookie four my gosh
okay
damn girl
how to resort to El Fuego
[Music]
no no no
oh my Lord Lord of Heaven have mercy on
my soul on my dirty soul
I literally hung pieces every move there
is
[Music]
I'm trying to go after that Bishop
unlike my position here
like at all
[Music]
no [__]
expecting that
[Music]
foreign
why did I do that
it was one of the stupidest things I've
ever done
[Music]
I'm gonna get him
he was pretty good okay Terry beat this
guy
[Music]
tired tired of losing to him all the
time
[Music]
literally my chest man
I mean it's like it's insane it's every
game I blunder something against them
and look at this position it's like a
random ass Fork
and he's got all the literally all this
time and on the clock
just it's just my kryptonite
okay I gotta try to Swindle him here
[Music]
okay something's up with his internet or
something
or or my internet
this is exactly what I need yeah he's
lagging
he's lagging but it doesn't matter
because he can pre-move the rest of the
game and find the best moves through
this freaking carry
okay but maybe he got nervous
gosh what
how
foreign
[Music]
I saved the draw I should have won that
but obviously it was not fair because he
lagged so I think it's a fair result
okay 12 teen good player but not amazing
I can beat him
yeah apologies to Terry that was uh
that was obviously a game he deserved to
win
okay what am I freaking doing here
let's get the pieces onto active squares
whoa really girl really girl
really girl you're gonna give me poems
like me the last time I saw a pawn
structure laughing when I was growing up
outside Charleston South Carolina
my uncle told me about Pawn structure he
had
just like that all right let's go here
okay freaking nergil salimova again
my favorite opponent
I never freaking Gill salima
okay
you
well I have very good positions
an hour
has some weaknesses say everywhere here
to create them
I didn't want this check so maybe not to
try with some sacrifices yes okay don't
blunder
um
Europe go after it just report
which she cannot defend
now black William yes
but like William also exchange Envy
resigns a game yes very nice very nice
okay but play Nico volkov whoever a good
player but okay we can beat him yes
because okay a very nice player but I've
been very good player
thank you
shoot
I've blundered like this before against
him too oh shoot wait I have this oh my
gosh and I lose
I mean are you freaking kidding me I
know is this how this is this how it's
gonna go down
or am I actually gonna Swindle him
is this how our life is gonna go down
a little bit worried about Bishop G4
okay suddenly I got chances
[Music]
um
let me do this
why am I sitting
I think I can go get away with this move
yeah but I don't like this he's very
fast
shoot
okay GG he deserved it there was not
there was nothing I could do
okay board Nick is somehow almost
catching up to me I gotta win
continuously I gotta build up another 15
or 20 games straight
oh this is a bad move
yeah I gotta do something against that
system that system's annoying actually
okay look at this
come on let's just not just winning on
the spot
okay all right Bishop G6 maybe but I
don't want to experiment
I think Bishop G6 is very strong
Bill explore bear girl okay oh yeah
wait why did I
flying so fast
literally no reason to be playing this
fast
foreign
of course I'm
getting exactly what I deserve out of
the opening
that is a bad position
okay let's not blunder let's go here
because C5 Knight D5
okay here I just gotta play well for a
couple moves
and I can win
[Music]
check
okay where do we want to go
let's go here
now I thought this move
oh here
[Music]
okay wait do I stop this one I do
Crescent Moon okay we're getting some
good opponents here
okay board Nick is winning and winning
and winning so I don't have to
put winning myself
probably a bad move whatever
wait here can I take maybe I can go like
this
I think with a pawn or something
okay I think I have a chance to take
this one
I don't know when I'll have the next
chance to do that
okay what does he want he wants queen
down so let's go back
now let's go here Back the Night
okay what does he want nothing
okay so let's take
[Music]
okay we need starters you love that
guy's beatable
foreign
[Music]
what am I doing
what am I freaking doing man I'm losing
oh
I'm gonna lose
unless he messed it up he's already
starting to mess it up
laughs
I need him to continue messing it up
why did I do that I'm so freaking stupid
now but if I lose games like this then I
don't have a chance to pull overall I
need to
I need to take these lower guys more
seriously
that's the thing
it's very important actually
foreign
[Music]
moves here
and there we go we want to Rook right
away I mean that was just a gift that
was a gift the lesson is you got to take
these guys more seriously you know these
these like
25 26 hundreds because they can play
[Music]
yeah I don't know how I won that I was
literally dead in the water in the end
game
okay I'm already winning
you had this again we had this earlier
and this is all it's all been played
before
it's over
Brooklyn here against dosto
okay let's just have let's end this
[Music]
come on dude resign please
go Quinn let's get another one just to
buttress that lead
okay India live very good but beatable
[Music]
okay let's just go E5 this has to work
thank you
um Rook E4 F4
probably that was wrong
wait what
he's just trying to confuse me in one on
time
it takes where's the wind here oh
foreign
I didn't see that oh no but I have this
and I still win ridiculous
unbelievable it's still made he can't
believe his eyes either okay we're
playing granindo dilshan the car started
to win games in about three seconds each
so I gotta do the same
thank you
okay this guy is very dangerous actually
[Music]
this guy is very dangerous
last day of entitled Tuesdays and stuff
[Music]
go a5a4
now I win
hopefully
no oh no no no I didn't mean it okay
whatever it's fine it's still winning
because of A3 I didn't mean to take with
a bishop but it's fine
foreign
promptly
yes he does okay Triumph mate
this guy as well
[Music]
okay what am I doing
like very poorly in the opening
[Music]
exactly how these games are bundled
it's okay mission's still solid
[Music]
bankrupt C6 is strong
we have three Queen F1 I've also Rook C2
okay now I went on the spot
oh [__] whatever
whatever
[Music]
it's waiting to pair me with someone
really good okay we're playing Indian
lad again very good pairing actually
[Music]
it's good but very beatable
um
[Music]
I think I can go here
with some counter play
Queen H4 is an idea here
[Music]
okay it's funny
or is my internet down
really dude
or is my isn't am I lagging
okay please tell me I'm not lagging guys
okay with my resignation okay we're
playing Lily karizay
foreign
big hello to Lily she's also a streamer
you can follow her on Twitch
if I play like this I'm gonna lose
what the hell am I doing
God she's playing incredibly actually
okay D6 I'm gonna take gotta open the
center up a little bit
[__]
one on earth am I doing
I'm trying trying to like break down her
defenses here a little bit
on here
okay now I think I'm in pretty decent
shape
okay I think I can just take this Pawn
Knight d70 threats I can go back and
centralize
I wanted to Rook D1 but it's okay
Knight F6 Bishop F6 is very important
okay still no threat so I can push
still no thread so I can push
and now I win
okay that was a really tough game
actually
okay it's still not over because I'm
playing like crap
okay now it's over
Detroit cleanse
all right Lily come on
it's not stale mate
Mr chess sponge okay
let's get him quickly
I almost played Queen C6 to fit him in a
horrible blender
okay another game that we can win
who is this this is Augustine drawing oh
I know I remember him
this guy used to play an ICC
um
you can go through H5 also
this game I'm playing very poorly but
it's fine
enough to win
okay he car is on a streak so we gotta
continue to win every single game for
the rest of the tournament
we know hikar is going to come back and
get amazing pairings the last like
couple minutes
wait what am I doing it's garbage
gotta Castle quickly
[Music]
yeah this is a very important game to
win
keep the streak going because the car is
on a big streak
oh [__]
oh no
not good but let's trade some pieces
just try to simplify the game
a little bit worried he goes Jeep butt
took tours right out of my mouth Buster
okay I'm gonna plug this
[Music]
imagine
I blended a fork but it's fine
okay oh honey and I'm in okay another
tough game
okay I like going to end games against
him because
he's a very tactical player
[Music]
um it's a good move
foreign
[Music]
choke this one a little bit
should still be able to win though
or not
seriously
there are Pepsi Marvel he made it GG
I mean listen I tried everything I could
try you made an honest genuine draw no
problem
what speed starters I love
no he's fast oh hanyan is one of the
fastest players in the world actually
he's in if you've ever seen him play 15
second chess on lead chess it's crazy
how fast he will beat me like five
seconds up rook vs Rook
I mean I was lost earlier in the game so
it's fine
should be a quick win
if I'm accurate
which I'm not
yeah this is winning
gotta win quickly here though you see
car is on a big streak again
just stick that guy
um let's just trade Queens in the end
game
this dragged down a lot longer than it
should have
what's that
what was that
I'm starting to get a little nervous and
literally have 30 Seconds To None and I
can calm down
okay we're playing Greek player this is
oh this guy's really good actually
okay Caro continues to Rampage a streak
[Music]
gonna win
now somehow he goes to B5 and he's still
alive but now not for long we win the
game quickly now we need to win another
one really quickly just to get that
three game streak up again
okay it's waiting okay Mr crucial we can
beat him
and be Mr crucial
[Music]
five is interesting
now to keep the tension on the board as
long as possible
it should be for
like end games against him but it's fine
the better end game
no and that's a terrible note
we'll move
and it's okay
now I have no way forward nice job
now I've got a flag of this
now like that
thing is crucial is really fast
of course he
I'm gonna win but this is awful
um hopefully I'm gonna win
okay we gotta not take the pawn as long
as possible basically no
what am I doing girl
I mean he literally is losing here
that's crazy he's literally losing in
the final position okay we're playing 12
team gotta win this one quickly
will not lose another hecarl in every
single game until the end of the bullet
brawl and we just know that
for just a fact
okay here
oh shoot I wondered but I have this move
somehow
okay now I'm winning completely
[Music]
um
I try to convert this
oh
wait that's not hanging
ah
let's bring this up
no
foreign
mate
come on man wake up
blender made in one or made into but at
that point it was already bad
it's completely winning earlier I think
just couldn't find the conversion
[Music]
it takes he's got six
I love this
[Music]
I need a car to lose a game that would
be a deal
this one I think I'm gonna win
okay Cara's on a huge streak now I mean
here we go with this again
we gotta win a couple games here just
and it's
his run
this one I think I'm gonna win no oh you
stupid idiot ah
the moment I say that
ugh girl
get your [__] shoot together
oh almost wondered that
Hikaru on again okay Magnus okay now
here we go the pairings
thank you
okay we gotta win
of course this always just goes for the
end game
all right Magnus I'm game
nah but I made a stupid move
okay I gotta keep the bishop at least
[Music]
um
yeah
[Music]
really Magnus really girl really
really
[Music]
okay but how do I win
yeah I can't okay I gotta go back
why did I freaking do that
that was really stupid
here
I'm so stupid
before
no wait no that doesn't work
[Music]
ah
no
no no no
you've gone oh my [__] gosh oh man
that sucks
oh
that's just very very bad luck very bad
luck
very very bad luck
very bad luck does Bishop B5 Bishop D3
and I win
okay back on the street
unbelievable
yeah I could sense that I was winning
and I got nervous and then I made one
bad pre-move literally just one
that's all it takes
okay this one I think I'm gonna win
don't trade Queens he's on time
foreign
now nobody's resigning also that's an
issue I need people to resign a little
bit more quickly
okay your car is going to catch up to me
it's pretty it's pretty obvious because
he's gonna get I know we play Magnus
again
and come on
seriously all right now what kind nice
what are these fairings
all right takes
earrings are brutal
and I blundered Queenie three
shakes takes maybe like this and then
take this guy
no this looks good for me
looks good for me again
I convert this time
um
oh no
all right
it's not the way that I wanted this to
go
I mean you can't make this stuff up
gray car with 167 I've got 178 so not
much of a chance given the pairings I'm
getting
and I gotta win all the non-magnus games
obviously
it's just a fact
foreign
[Music]
no that was another terrible move
okay got that one
your car already cut up
I mean listen I'm doing what I can
I'm beating everybody whose name is not
Magnus Carlson the pairings are always
ridiculous you know but it is what it is
there's nothing I can do to change it
I got Magnus twice in in four games
and he car is getting 2100s probably I
don't know I haven't checked experience
maybe he's beating tough guys
but
you know I've learned that that's just
the way things go in in these
tournaments the pairings always screw
you in the end
trying to trap his Queen here let's go
F5 Cooper mate
what am I doing now I'm like not focused
I need to focus
I can't lose to a 2100.
which is exactly what I'm doing
[Music]
okay he blundered made in one that helps
okay I'm on oh my God I want to beat him
on
um
foreign
by the way check out my anguin video
if you want to know how to refute this
is garbage
Magnus vs Naka let's go Magnus you got
this my my anger
just like I taught you and Charleston
South Carolina
I I ain't teach you for nothing girl
why am I freaking doing this oh now I
gotta mate him
no I gotta made him
shoot oh my God am I actually gonna
choke this away
it must be some way and I'm gonna lose
I'm gonna I'm gonna have to let him
promote and then try to go for me
and I'm
oh shoot
did I literally just listen to him on
I literally just freaking do this did I
literally just want to do this man ah
I literally just did this
I'm doing everything to choke this
tournament everything
lost my focus for one millisecond
s
of course of course
of course up a queen too
okay Bara
freaking believable
stuff a queen
this one I have to win
it was pretty straightforward I think
they call this Pawns back
before is a weird move
trying to trick me somehow but he's
losing all his points and now a rook
okay that should be a quick win
unless I choke this as well but I don't
think I can
yeah
now we got a quick resign
and let's get up a streak
okay now we got Jocelyn
and if I had beaten them on I think that
would have been the tournament but it is
what it is
oh we want G4
and G4
how could I
I mean Jesus
you want freaking G4
[Music]
yeah can't make this stuff up
okay this guy is beautiful
okay let's let's get on a streak in the
tournament that's what I have to do
okay that's a quick win he just loses a
piece okay he's got to resign
you gotta resign man
gotta resign
down a full Rook
there we go
hikara passed me let's kick his ass
oh Bishop have six he had third time
it's always happened
foreign
I appreciate it we held it
yeah he was winning for sure but
not easy to convert those types of end
games
okay we gotta beat this guy quickly
I really appreciated that
I mean he could have tried to flag me I
mean it could have backfired also
because you can blender The Rook in
those types of positions
okay G6 GF I took this guy
this is winning
but can I get it quickly is the question
probably here
um maybe Knight B5
trying to get up some tactics try to win
quickly
[Music]
okay Pedro Martinez now it's all about
the parents
can't believe I lost that one to Amman I
just took my foot off the gas pedal
briefly
the the mental lapse there
with Magnus it's mostly mental
okay I can see the standings folks
people one request people don't have to
read out the standings
I I can read and I can see the standings
just as a request
yes the world champion has won some
games
hard to believe but a fact
I'm gonna have to go for like very quick
wins here which is I'm gonna have to
take some gambles
[Music]
well ding oh shoot it's ding World
Champion's ding okay that tells you
everything you need to know about the
state of Chess right now
I I've done this before too
where I was doing like a chess.com video
and I'm like yes we're watching the
world champion play oh re-record
oh and I've Leonard
amaze me
[Music]
okay I'm still okay here obviously
I'm probably more than okay
although the way I'm playing
[Music]
foreign
as the question
no he will not
didn't think he would
now
[Music]
he did
okay we're playing okay we're getting
some easy pairings here which is good
[Music]
trying to win quickly here just to
generate the points
okay help if she resigned
I have blender 95 okay
I need her to resign
okay now I need another easy pairing
please
thank you much thank you much
who else but Terry and he's beatable
though he ain't complain
foreign
[Music]
Sasha
no I currently played the outcome
against him now he knows what I've what
I feel every every day
every day of my life
oh
wait why did I do any of that
um
tactics I don't see any
C5
no don't go fish Buffet
foreign
the game
both team okay gotta be the beat of this
dude please resign
come on
girl come on girl
Rebecca is not happy about this Behavior
Rebecca's happy about this Behavior how
do you like that huh
want some more of that Magnus decaro huh
that was a mouse slip by the way
[Music]
[__] okay this is bad
oh oh
homely defend calmly defend he will make
a mistake calmly defend
wait out all the good moves he will make
a mistake he will blunder
he's nervous
[Music]
no these tournaments are fun I mean this
is where the this is what I enjoy the
most about what I do is like these these
tournaments these moments it's fun it's
emotional but it's really really fun at
the end of the day obviously
there's positive and negative moments to
it
and you know I'm upset if I don't win
but
at the end of the day and the money
isn't serious so we're just having fun
okay now he needs to resign
Magnus actually surpassed tikaru he's on
a huge trick now I need to get I gotta
get like one or two easy pairings it's
waiting to pair with pair me with Magnus
I just know it and look at this
it's yeah Magnus Leo Leo Magnuson
Leo his name is Leo Carlson
his Spanish cousin Leo don't you see
[Music]
okay the thing is I gotta take these
people seriously
I'm actually playing like Raptor
I'm actually playing terribly in this
game oh my gosh am I freaking losing
I actually am losing
[Music]
he's gonna get nervous and blunder but
it's a different story
[Music]
I mean I'm on the board I'm losing but
okay not anymore of course
he's not he's not bad this guy
um God damn it make a move Daniel
Jesus
and then he's six I have to I have to do
this
okay I'm gonna win on the clock here I'm
pretty confident but
95 he's gonna find that too
that's about this pay grade
okay I'm gonna win this one it's not the
way I wanted to win it but it's still a
win
dude he's good
is this a 2000
you win this one playing mono David
gotta win this one too
I know I'm trading everything
yes this movement is not scary
[Music]
oh I didn't see the cleanest came in
hanging there but whatever
[Music]
oh man he equalized
I dare he
[Music]
the problem is it's the freaking lag
comp so now I have to be fast and I have
to be very very accurate
let's see is about six hours per move
foreign
[Music]
now we gotta win about 16 more games
because Carlson is going to catch up to
me okay Savita excellent
excellent
just kidding
[Applause]
all right
this is Kavita actually
change your name
okay I think this wins
now we gotta win another one after this
one because Carlson is going to win 600
games in two seconds we just know it
crap Rook C3 the bullion
okay but I have this okay I'm still in
pretty good shape here
Daniel
I think
let me just trade is fine I'm winning in
the same game oh The Rook was saying
doesn't matter
it's still winning
Stigler Pawns
okay we gotta win another one
and then another one after that another
one after that
this just wins I think he might resign
here
no he's not gonna resign down in
exchange in 700 points got it
thank you
what if I take another one
bro are you serious right now
do you even lift
[Music]
okay I love how Magnus just oh of course
of course I get ikaro
Magnus just continues to win in like
five seconds a game
let's freaking go right out of the
jibava course take it and eat it
all in the course
all every move was in the course
now the thing is right after this I
gotta play the title Arena
so I won't be able to celebrate for too
long
I'll have to play the title to rain on
Lee chess
that's it it's over two minutes to go
I'm in clear first with 20 extra points
and I'm winning another one
just to make sure Magnus doesn't catch
up
for good measure ladies and gentlemen
for good measure
how about another one
let's win another one again Hikaru
and he's in second place
at least tilted as hell
I'm not giving him a draw
actually I mean if he wants it sure
fine I'll give him a draw
I mean I he's gonna stall it out anyway
so
I don't care I mean I don't know who who
that favors if it favors Matt probably
favors Magnus because he currently gets
a point off that game but who knows
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna play
you know
I'm not gonna be an [__]
foreign
another one
um what is this
I mean I'm just trying to
it's We're not gonna have time to make
it anyway here
it's fine Hikaru I think gets second
yeah okay 20 seconds this game will Auto
abort so obviously I'm losing it it
doesn't matter
unless he wants to get checkmated
LOL
and we got it
242 to 218
let's go finish officially fantasy with
20 subs thank you very much
yeah I'm happiest of the fact that I
didn't I didn't tilt when Hikaru caught
up just kept winning
there was a there was a scary time when
I lost the Magnus twice but just kept my
cool and uh obviously
built up another uh another big big gap
of course the the first bullet brawl
with a the smaller price fund I win
all right I gotta play the Lee chess
tied at Arena
um and I don't have to play it but I
want to play it
thank you yeah I played very well today
thank you stress for the sub 300 bits
from Gokul I can I can take a couple
minutes it's a three hour Arena so it's
really not
not uh
essential to play every second
thanks everybody hope you enjoy the
content I'll see you later tonight
[Music]